what's up guys happy Monday morning
welcome to make a bit I'm Peter Brown
here with my friend max Hobart last week
we wrote a little retrospective feature
on Donkey Kong Country it's a favor on
the office and it was the second
best-selling game on the Super Nintendo
Wow
so to honor that feat and became History
Month or gonna be playing Donkey Kong
Country today all right well let's see
how far we can get we're gonna start
from the very beginning I'm not an
expert in this game the whole story is
donkey kong stock pile of bananas is has
been ransacked right so now he goes to
the ends of the earth to get his bananas
back I guess so make sure controllers
are working here can you control him now
no I got nothing nothing oh you're gonna
die you got a lot of like different
friends in this game that's the finnex
name is like right called stampy yeah
they've got a lot of like great sections
where you're riding in like mine carts
even under water levels which I usually
hate hmm
don't question it no just it was the 90s
I want to know who's putting monkeys and
barrels in the water yeah
oh you can get it back I'm gonna be back
out all right good job that's the best
no no I don't wanna man what have you
done oh there oh wow oh cool what the
doggy humming Diddy Kong in the end it's
building this world and all the other
animals are just trying to get by
monkeys combine to screw their a-game up
all the time
good the game of life I mean the intro
the intro is dougie car and drop it in
on cranky yeah yeah and maybe kick all
of those bananas by like robbing other
animals those bananas are a trip so this
is when it gets tough when you're using
this sort of setup because there's like
a few frames of delay when you're
upscaling these old systems on HDTV
these levels are really unforgiving
these are really interesting the new
game because there's like you're doing
it in a sawmill so instead of on card
screens like wooden rafts and as you do
it like saws chop your wrap in half and
it's like jump onto a new one like over
a saw
oh no oh you're right there is a little
bit of delay oh I wouldn't lie Donkey
Kong Country fanfiction art is already
as rough
I really need damn it - give it dammit
alright okay no one it's like a cocky
doubt you're gonna throw we have the
last time 13 tries it's not it's not
gonna be one try and and damn you let's
try it's a great game
oh wait Lee oh my goodness
No if you don't memorize this you get
have all my reflexes yeah it's jumper no
sir go see that yeah yeah oh damn it
I don't know I should be proud of the
fact that we might do this for the
entire segment nope no I should be
ashamed no yeah
oh you've got like half a second to
react to these things when you've got
delay oh I think they're live crews fall
asleep
new he's coming in
on the next jump here yeah yeah whoops
yeah I'm about to turn on myself I think
[ __ ]
and that's chance don't [ __ ] it up screw
Dance Crew Erik they're gonna have to
kick me off the air because I'm not
going to give up [ __ ] all right talk
about sorry everybody thanks for
watching us try really hard to beat that
one level for the past 35 minutes hey
come back next week for megabit stay
tuned GameSpot for all retro game
content coming this month everyday for
me to game history month until next time
thanks for watching guys
see you Monday